Carly has brought to us this European
legal perspective whoa
so I changed the title and I also
tweaked the the subject because it
because you put me at the back of the
session that made it possible for me to
see what this audience might be able to
relate to and I thought this is much
more interesting for you also because
you're basically interested in potential
privacy I had taken the beyond a bit too
far I think I was going to talk about
what happens when in law you move from
text driven law which is what we now
have to data driven and code driven law
and for those people who especially came
for that topic I did add two slides at
the back so actually I want to start
with this this is what is called brain
teaser why am I putting this brain
teaser all up front part from amusing
you it is a point I want to make and
that point is that it shows that
perception and cognition in the rise of
a person of a human subject come second
what comes first is interacting with an
environment here you see that because
the brain knows that human faces have
two eyes in one mouth when it gets to
see this picture it is just calibrating
until this becomes a normal human face
but because it's getting other signals
that doesn't work so you basically want
me to remove this picture as soon as
possible because your brain like it we
are used to think that first you observe
something you look at something you
understand it and then you act
this is what we have learned that's an
accomplishment I think it is it has a
lot to do with our ability to speak in
natural language it's the result of that
but before we come down to that and when
you look at other organisms there is
this interaction with the environment
that basically determines what you are
going to see of course depending on your
biological makeup so I want to talk
about privacy as the protection of the
incomputable self when we went out
hiking we were asked to put up a topic
for discussion I put up this question
because after the end of the second day
I thought oh okay there seems to be a
presumption here that privacy is
something that you can completely
compute I think that's a that's a
fundamentally flawed assumption and
because of this floor is also dangerous
because if you assume that you are
producing blind spots and the agility of
your mind
and if anybody has a j'l Minds I believe
from my own experiences computer
scientists you're basically limiting
constraining that agility I had said
that I would take a hike towards the
music cafe bookshop on Bancroft and when
I just arrived for the first time or
sorry on Sunday or something here I went
to this place because I loved it when I
was here before and they had this it
wasn't really stale so I'm going back to
this I already pointed this out when I
gave my unbaked ideas so when you talk
about things that are countable or that
are made countable making something
comfortable the fact that you can count
it doesn't mean that it counts in the
sense of that it matters so not
everything that is countable counts not
everything that counts is countable and
I think this insight is core to my
presentation
so if this is what you don't agree with
I'm very curious but it might be that
you will disagree with the entire
presentation I think this statement can
also bridge between computer scientists
and lawyers and that's and maybe others
but let's let's speak about law and
computer science so there's a paper
underlying this where many of the things
that I will only touch from are further
discussed or talked briefly about
differential privacy and I will say that
what makes differential privacy
interesting and salient and functional
is that actually it's saying that the
individual doesn't matter because you
are creating databases you're creating
an aggregate and you can remove somebody
from that add your bread and basically
it's still saying the same thing then
you're inferring patterns from that
aggregate in such a way that an
individual doesn't matter so in a way
that that thing that mechanism
differential privacy says individuals
don't matter that's interesting to
remember I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with that as long as it is it to
to do something good then I will talk
about privacy is the protection of the
incomputable self I will conclude from
that that the fact that this is the main
argument of the paper the fact that
things are not computable means that
they are computable in different ways so
many people will say you know let's say
the romantic part of humanity will say
that's not what I'm talking about
this interesting yeah but there's no one
talking about what I'm saying is if you
do if you make something computable that
is an act and you can always do that in
different ways depending on your
assumptions and all the goal of making
things computable so the best thing you
can ever do is make the same thing
computable in different ways because it
will give you the blacks black spots
like when you drive in a car and there's
this one spot you don't see so this is
the main argument and that will evolve
towards an argument for agonistic
machine learning which means when you
start developing a machine learning
research design you should get in domain
experts that hopefully always happens
that's normal but you should also get in
the people that are going to be affected
by the application as soon as possible
that will cover better your blind spots
it will inform how you make trade-offs
there is no machine learning research
design that does not involve all kinds
of trade-offs so the question is not to
develop a machine learning research
design that has no trade-offs whoever
claims that is bullying you very curious
about your response to this whoever
claims that is bullying is trying to
intimidate no you can always find
trade-offs and what is important is to
put them on the table and then to say
what are the implications of these
trade-offs and then to make it practical
and say okay we think this machine
learning application is good we want AI
feel good and all that deeply ethical
stuff so let's bring in the right people
and sit down and decide what trade-offs
are acceptable and that's of course also
distribution of risks and if there is
time I will say something about
the other subjects so briefly about
differential privacy as I have
understood it does oh yes what's very
important I believe that whatever
technology is introduced into society so
this is not about developing new
mathematical models this is about once
you take them out of the lab out of the
academia into society
you must always ask three questions and
after that you can do your risk benefit
analysis etc cost-benefit and risk
analysis these questions come first
which problem are you solving okay which
problems are you not solving maybe the
problems that you're not solving are the
real problems third question what
problem are you creating when you
introduce new technologies they will
create problems and after you've
carefully looked at this you can go
ahead or not now what I understand the
problem that differential privacy sauce
is it reduces the risks of detecting
personal data in aggregate data one and
two it enables you to obtain statistical
research sorry research results while
protecting against re identification
that's what I see are the problems that
are solved and that's important and
let's come back to that what problem is
not solved yes if your information in
the database and yeah yeah so yeah so
this is so this is a qualification this
actually relates what I said earlier it
doesn't only do this but it does it in a
way that doesn't diminish the value of
the set of the aggregate data and of the
model right yeah that's a very important
qualification yeah so the problem with
making slides
I was trying to say this two sentences
don't don't match with a fashion privacy
this is like a small part of what
differential privacy is doing but I'm
talking about the problem being solved
in terms of protection okay and the
problem that it solves is much harder
than what is written in your slide so
what is the my particular what amis was
referring to is that it can provide
guarantees on on on harms that are not
shown here that it provides which harms
are not shown here no problems are shown
here like this does not speak about my
bananas yeah the factual privacy has
succinct way to to deal with privacy
comes with risk and this is not
represented here and also the pressure
privacy gates tools gives protection
when we have multiple analysis that are
running which is also not so I would
need like sixteen slides to explain more
precisely what differential privacy is I
agreed and you know that better than me
and I want to make a presentation that
goes beyond differential privacy so if I
have to do the whole presentation on
differential privacy I will not get
beyond saying that differentially the
special process that thinks that people
don't matter or things like that this is
not a fair representation so okay but
I'm not going to now at this moment make
a new slide presentation right so you're
saying this is not fair that's very
interesting in relation to discussions
about machine learning fairness etc so
I'm point taken and and I move on and
let's see so let's move to the problems
that it does not solve
or it doesn't solve is the manipulative
not the manipulation I'm not interested
in manipulation I'm interested in
manipulable 'ti so the extent to which
these systems machine learning
applications not mathematical models
applications are capable of pre-empting
behavior by way of nudging etc now you
could say that and correct me if I'm
wrong that differential privacy is about
the construction of aggregate data the
construction of inferences from that
Agra data that's where it is focused on
where I think are very important
problems and at this moment I even think
the most important problems is what
happens after you have the inferences
how these inferences are capable of
manipulating people that problem is not
addressed and so not solved by
differential privacy problems I would
like to push back on this first second
is here
but the second one is completely wrong
because no machine learning technique
regardless water it cares about
individual or not okay because were
individuals make a difference or not in
that technique no none of these
techniques helps through and protecting
the first bullet so I don't think this
is related to the fact that independent
privacy has this requirement that the
outcome would not depend on individual
coffee makers also don't exactly salt a
manipulative little problem but that's
because they're like not just so it
applies to lots of Technology because
they're survivors to set up a strong ale
in here that it's like okay so I think
when I realized when the in the first
day I think of first in the second day
where there was an explanation about
what differential privacy actually does
that it means that you're basically
telling somebody if we not just this
person but whoever wants to use the
application I'm not talking about math
who wants to use the application that
you can safely withdraw people from it
and still have the same value knowledge
in the aggregate and still have the same
valid inferences that's the whole point
as far as I understand that means that
you are developing a technology I'm not
talking about the math but about the
applications because I'm a lawyer and
I'm here for the people that get stuck
with the applications yeah so I have no
problem with the math I wouldn't even
dare to say anything about it because
this you know much better but you're
developing a technology that claims
matically that one person in that set
doesn't matter in that sense I'm not
saying anything very special right
that's the the fundamental idea of
differential privacy I don't see
anywhere what the professional policies
say that persons don't matter this is
not a mathematical concept from a
mathematical perspective you agree right
that this is what differential privacy
talks about people and says that they
measure don't measure so this is what
you were telling me the first two days
so if it's not true I'm sorry then I
misunderstood
so whether they're in or out of this how
about let's beam the previous ones you
could say that individuals don't matter
to the law in the same way it's a
there's just like a basic linguistic
mismatch okay
differential privacy guarantees an
individual doesn't substantially matter
to the output this is why we with so
that is on under the problems that it
solve it's a it's a technique that by by
assuming that it is possible to develop
this system in such a way that the the
individual entity data of a particular
person do not make a difference for the
aggregate and do not make a difference
for the inferences by doing this you
achieve this okay I take it that some
people are not going to agree with that
what problems are created here well I
think that one of the problems that is
that may occur and this is not ever the
fault of mathematicians I'm not saying
that there's anything wrong with the
development of these models but if this
becomes implemented then you are
basically legitimizing the building of
huge aggregates because you will say
well this is we're protecting
individuals you're legitimizing the
inferences that are drawn from it
because you think two things we're
protecting the individual one two
we're getting the same quality of
knowledge as if we didn't do that yeah
this legitimization might mean that this
sort of inferences are going to be used
to target people to nudge people to
preempt people to change the choice
architecture of people I'm not saying
that that is because of your
mathematical model I'm saying that that
is because that is how it's going to be
employed and I have a problem with the
targeting I have a problem so if you
make the targeting more accurate you
might not increase utility for society
but you might decrease utility for
society because you're doing something
very dangerous and people will say it's
certified its differentially private so
there's no problem because as we know
there is an incentive structure where
some people will use this argument which
safeguards this part of the process to
do something nasty or maybe they think
it's great with that part of the process
now this analysis is necessary and I'm
not saying differential privacy is wrong
but if you do not accept that this is
the consequence of what you are
producing then you can't it's very
important to realize that because then
you can begin to anticipate that people
might use it that way and you can put a
disclaimer out and say look at you
solving this problem but it's not
solving that problem and we're not sure
how to deal with that problem for some
people is the same but I never use the
term you know but I agree with
everything you've said right but I also
think that it is not just a problem with
differential party I think differential
privacy is in part responding to the way
in which we've focused concerns they're
a legal lens that has been focused on
yeah III agreed though I wouldn't agree
for the gdpr but I agree with the data
privacy focus on hiding data I always
when I came to this field and I dare I
totally agree I've put in some slides on
the gdpr to argue that the gdpr goes
further into that but I certainly do not
believe that the gdpr is going to solve
all the problems and I think that
competition law there are many other
things that are absolutely ok explain
how the federal policy created profiling
and micro targeting hasn't these things
happened before the fire legit amazing
it by giving it a stamp that it's
privacy I'm saying you and I shouldn't
say that because I'm not saying that you
are doing this but if this gets apply to
this problem I can breathing in this
bullet what problems does it create and
the prong is profiling in mark the
target ok so maybe it's important to
differentiate between a mathematician
that is developing a model to protect
personal data and a market at which the
results of that in the form of an
application is going to be used in
real-world situations I understand you
differential privacy for profiling and
micro targeting these are things that
happened years before the fan service
existed so differential privacy at the
beginning she said is the deployment the
instantiation of this concept within a
technological within an application and
a product so you're focused and are
getting very upset that it says
differential practicing it's sliding
maybe that's a problem of the graphic
design of the slide when it should say
the use of differential privacy within a
commercial product that is deployed by
an actor who is not the people in this
room would not say legitimate but I
think from like the way I listen to the
practitioners and and this resonates
with me what you say is that a lot of
people who don't know what this
technology is feel like it's solving
these problems and I think what you
point out is that feeling that that that
incorrect product that it could solve
these problems is something worse making
salient because it doesn't and I put all
of you say that this semester that that
it you know but we can't protect the
groups we can't this is not a technique
that helps with this it's not designed
for that and that's okay and I think all
you're doing is highlighting that I can
understand what the content but I think
that presentation is also very important
when you present things this way this is
a way to kill it a concept because
you're blaming a lot of stuff on this
concept even if it's just graphically
whereas the education system that people
have not been educated to read math and
understand it be critical that's a
different thing but maybe if I don't do
it that way maybe then the product gets
solved and people don't realize it and
and then you're not educating people
properly if you want to sell the idea
not even the application but the idea of
differential privacy you have to tell
people this otherwise you are not
ethically professionally edge
getting people hopefully papers we tell
this version of papers the papers out
there I mean exactly to translate a
concept for for women a concept I'm
saying it does good things that are
think no it does good things it does
things it doesn't solve everything in
the world and it creates new problems
the problem of legitimization and that's
huge that's a huge problem and I'm sure
that this is not ever what you want
right this is not your intent but you
have to take into account that that's
how it might go into the world and
that's very important because it might
it might do this then and that's
precisely what you don't want to do
wonder if a person what you say tell me
that stays there so there are two groups
of individuals in the dataset on which
you're running you're in random order
the first prophecy talks about the
privacy of individuals but then the
model itself then goes into the world
and as access to new a drink tap and the
question is the information privacy or
other concerns of the individuals that
are outside it is we're saying fragile
privacy talks about the promise of you
inside they just say the people may
interpret even saying that whatever is
the result here those who provide
privacy okay so what I'm saying is there
are two things you want you may want to
hide identifiable data that's that's one
problem that can be solved in part by
differential privacy but there's another
problem and that is micro targeting so
you have an inference which says people
which share these five data points in
sixty-seven percent of the cases you're
going to buy your product or vote on
this party or whatever I think that has
nothing to do with differential privacy
and what I'm saying is it's very
important to acknowledge that but my
concern here is that by saying we're
going to do the aggregate data and the
inferences in a way that protects the
privacy of the people that we're using
construction that this might create a
legitimization here and and that's all
not blaming anybody or blaming concepts
that's not my job I want this on the
table and I think it's the sooner the
community who is developing this tool
acknowledges that and builds in walls to
prevent that the better because you're
actually the only people who can really
do that if you leave it to others people
might say oh it's not good but if you do
it because you know how it can save
people from being realized and all the
privacy harms that that are mentioned
that I couldn't all fit other that what
problems does it solve so so you for you
it's very important to take this home
yeah okay so so we have a technology
that I is not designed to protect
against tornado
great you're concerned about learning
statistical properties and population
you find some applications of this
disturbing and so I think we'll be
productive here is maybe to try to
understand when is it problematic to
learn statistical properties of a yes
yes and there is many much out debt now
I'm not a formalization person so I'm
not going to tell you how to do that but
I want to go on with the next slides
because I'm not going to explain to you
how to do differential practicing
because you know that much better yeah
it's good to just move on and say the
differential privacy as an idea and once
it is applied into technologies into I
would hope at the moment when you build
a system machine learning computing
system so we call that privacy by design
instead of privacy enhancing
technologies so not as an adult but at
the moment when you build the system
well there are many other tools like
homomorphic encryption safe answer open
private data safe technologies of
Pentland i'm not at all a fan of that
but i know it's out there in a lot about
my colleagues developed polymorphic
encryption and should organization for
confidential data like medical data
student data very interesting technology
it does other things and then there is
the technology of attribute base
potentials against interesting it does
other things so differential privacy
protects personal data but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it protects a
person there's obvious it's like saying
it doesn't protect a cat from falling
from the roof right yes so that's what I
mean
now what is very important here and I've
already announced it privacy is not
computable but that means it can be
computed in many different ways and by
using ok I'm going to come to that I'm
going to come to so
computability can be used in two senses
and of course I'm playing with that
right in the first part of the sentence
I use it another sense in the second
part in the first part I'm saying
anybody who claims that they can
formalize privacy completely is doing
something dangerous and intimidating
it's not possible there are very many
different concepts of privacy and the
concepts depend on the environment on
relationship between the agent whose
privacy you want to protect and that
environment etc etc so computability in
depth you as a computer scientists also
cannot define it we're talking about
sure but it's also a real thing that
aims to protect people here take that
serious ok I'll come to that I'll come
to that so
so my position and I've worked on this
for 17 years now that the biggest
challenge of the fact that the self as
you see I'm moving from privacy to self
because privacy about protecting the
self is incomputable is not in real
identification of personal data in
aggregated data or models but the bigger
challenge I believe is in the
application of the models that have been
inferred especially because it is very
difficult for people to anticipate how
these models are applied to them I'm not
telling you anything new you know that
you've seen it we all know that we care
very much about this I'm not trying to
say that differential privacy is not
important
I'm not saying anything like that this
workshop was supposed to be about beyond
so I'm trying to look with this last
statement you're you making a value
statement that in your perception and
the research you've done you came to the
conclusion that the the bigger few
people have no no this is my concern the
algorithmic decision-making rather than
finding something out about an
individual like the actual value well
personal data yeah so this is my concern
I'm not saying that this is what 51% of
the population I'm not interested in
averages I'm trying to protect people
from a constitutional rights perspective
lack of perspective of course but this
is I think the bigger concern and
evidently one can disagree about that
some people think hiding personal data
is the most important concern ever I
think that distracts attention from the
manipulative that is created with the
inferred knowledge
but I'm not saying that it is not
important yeah just one minor board
issue right so what is preemption so
preemption means that you are predicting
that somebody is going to stop eating
meat because you've inferred that from
their online serf behavior so you guess
they're going to be they might be let's
say there's a chance of 83% that they
will be vegetarian this knowledge this
predictive knowledge knowledge between
inverted commas of course can be salted
meat industry who might have access to
particular types of nudging machine
learning applications that allow to send
me for instance three scientific papers
because they will know I'm a scientist
an academic they will somehow can be
three academic papers that show that
eating meat is extremely healthy that
you actually get that's good for your
brains yeah I'm not aware that this is
done because somebody has inferred that
I might switch to being a vegetarian I'm
not aware of that and then I think that
I'm fully autonomously deciding because
I've seen these papers to continue
eating meat that is what I mean with
manipulative with preemption so before I
actually move on to do something my
environment my choice architecture the
information I get is changed in such a
way that the prediction is that the
chance that I become a vegetarian is now
not what did I say 63 but 43% that's
what I mean with preemption so it's like
the manipulable 'ti that I refer to
because there was some confusion I think
about the GDP art I thought it would be
very good idea to put in some slides of
the gdp arm but i'm gonna keep it very
short because we're
we already have to skip part of the
presentation which is perfectly fine by
me because this is a conversation this
is not a lecture right but I do want to
do that and I also want to tell you that
I've taught a lot to computer scientists
master students of computer science for
80 years and this is been a pleasure I
always say it was party time I'm now on
a research professional ship completely
so I've stopped and in the last course
that I gave while giving the course I
wrote a book it's going to be published
in open access by Oxford University
Press and it's going to be on MIT open
access community review open review
within two weeks and I would love to
send you a link and I would love to get
good proper feedback like what are you
talking about I don't understand this
should be nonsense bla bla bla very
[Music]
quickly about the relationship between
differential privacy in the GDP are
first of all the GDP our addresses
controllers not computer scientists no
developers developers have no liability
no liability and I think that's a very
good thing puts the stuff on the market
or whatever government agency uses it
that should be addressed so first of all
from a very practical perspective I
would say in many of my practicing
lawyer colleagues say assume that the
data that you are processing is personal
data maybe it is sadhana mised and as
somebody tweeted this morning maybe it's
anonymized but it's definitely not going
to be anonymous maybe for a short while
but the chance that it becomes reaiiy
don't file in this fast-moving
environment is very good so for very
practical reasons just assume that
make sure you have a valid legal ground
and as you know there are six valid
legal grounds consent contract vital
interests of the data subject public
task or exercise of public authority
legal obligation that is a statutory
obligation or the legitimate interest of
the data controller that may be an
economic interest but in that case
somebody can object and it may be that
the fundamental rights and freedoms and
interests of the data subject overrule
that legitimate interest so that ground
is complex it's complicated the consent
crowd is a weak ground if you can do
without it do without it because there
are too many requirements under the GPR
and we've already heard yesterday one of
the requirement is that anybody should
be able to withdraw their consent at any
moment that means all the processing
operations up to that point are valid
nothing wrong but from that moment
onward the data should actually be what
is more beautiful that withdrawal should
be as easy as giving consent so
basically if you have a website with a
button consent you should be able to
push no I would draw my consent as
easily with a button that is as flies as
much in your face well then you have to
check whether you're processing
article 9 data and that will often be
inferred data so from for proxies if you
can infer that you were gay that you are
Muslim what have you then that there is
a basic prohibition and you're only
allowed to process if one of the
exceptions apply that can be consent but
the consent requirement here is even
more stringent
and we'll come to the research exception
so now when you aggregate behavioral
data so these social networks encircle a
view and if you compress the data that
you have aggregated to a target function
or they say the approximation of an
assumed target function in that case
it's very wise to conduct a data
protection impact assessment and the
impact you're assessing is the impact on
fundamental rights and freedoms of the
data subjects there's much more than
that
just checking boxes and it means it
requires a precautionary approach it's
not just some sort of risk assessment
precautionary approach you have to err
on the side of caution the cautionary
approach means that you building
uncertainty which is not the same as
risk the same goes for applying data
protection by default that's data
minimization so here this is a legal
obligation this article that is article
25 isn't it
25 or 35 always mix them up so there is
a legal obligation to build in data
protection by default I think
differential privacy in certain cases if
it becomes state-of-the-art and is
economically feasible will be an
obligation so so here you have your hook
then you have to check whether you're
making yes to the people that gave me
information is the blind doctor left is
the Machine there Mulder this is always
the GDP our addresses controllers so
it's the controller that is the entity
legal person or ever who determines the
purpose because they're both data
subjects and in the second case there is
last thing so if you make automated
decisions in the sense of article 22
that means a decision that is fully
automated and that has significant
effect or legal effect and fully
automated as defined by the advisory
body that CDP be now European data
protection board fully automated means
that if you try to do window dressing
and you say oh but we have a real
natural person you know this lady is
sitting there and she looks into her
screen and then the system says you have
to make a decision a and then she makes
decision a and then we are outside
article 22 the EPB has said no you're
not outside 22
because there are two requirements if
such a person disqualifies the automated
decision that person must one understand
how the decision was taken well think
machine learning systems must understand
it and two must have the competence to
take another decision these are two very
heavy requirements so if you just put
somebody there who is window dressing it
will still count as a decision in the
sense of article 22 these decisions are
prohibited oh ma unless one of three
exceptions apply and that that is
consent of course contract another one
legal obligation safeguards if one of
the exceptions apply applies you must be
able to obtain human intervention and
very specific transparency requirements
apply so you must be told not just when
you ask but as soon as the system is an
operation you must be told that the
decision that was taken about you was an
automated decision you must be told
meaningful information about the logic
of that system and you visit
consequences as you can understand
libraries have already been filled with
what that means yeah so I'm going to go
very fast two minutes you say right so I
met slide 11 of around 30 starts
but but this makes discussions very
interesting okay so there is a very
broad exception for scientific research
there doesn't mean that if you are under
that exception that you do not need a
proper legal ground one of those six and
then if you're processing sensitive data
which also includes inferred data that
are sensitive then you will have to have
one of the exceptions of article nine
because their processor is writing for
prohibited
okay so differential privacy might
contribute to water cycle 162 says the
result of processing for statistical
purposes not being personal data but
aggregate data that might mean that it
remains outside of the scope of the GDP
are on one of the last slides I have
article 162 if you're interested in the
Q&A we can see requirements are already
mentioned now the interesting question
is how to go back to what I actually
wanted to say so I'm going to skip very
quick oh this is a nice one so I I think
this is a cartoon about behaviorism
right much of the processing of
behavioral data is based on let's say a
particular type of doing social science
which is also very influential in
economics I think that from a scientific
perspective you can have many many
objections against this type of science
I would dare to profess and I have
written about that that this is
pseudoscience so if you give a dog a few
change choices and then the dog makes
one of those choices
and then you want to draw enormous
conclusions about what dogs are like
from that particular situation you are
taking people for a ride this has
nothing to do with how dogs actually
behave and if you want to know something
about that don't restrain their choice
of course this is trying to do something
with living organisms that works very
well in the Natural Sciences with non
living organisms we all know it is
necessary and also in mathematics to say
blur that I put some parameters fix them
because then we can test something else
if you do that with living entities you
get pseudoscience alright so I'm going
to go very fast yes so so can I have
three more minutes so about agonistic
machine learning because this isn't this
I think is important and interesting for
you when you develop a research machine
learning research design you're going to
do a lot of things like select the data
curate the data in the social domain I'm
not even talking about the social
sciences yet but in a social domain most
of the behavioral data are low-hanging
fruit they're just what you can easily
grasp it doesn't mean it's the data you
need not all second you're going to
develop a feature space you're going to
say ok these variables I'm gonna pick
out because I think they're relevant
here we get all the biases that you can
possibly conceive of that confirmation
bias is a FIFO bias that I introduced in
the unbaked ideas etc you have to
formulate a machine-readable task
otherwise the system can't do anything
that means you have to answer the
question what you are asking the
algorithm the learner algorithm to
optimize for
was actually deciding that then you're
going to develop a hypothesis space now
some people might think that's objective
because it's a computer and because it's
mathematics but I'm sure you understand
that this is not objective at all if you
are in a hurry if you want to constrain
the space there are very many different
ways to do this so then you're going to
choose performance metric imagine if you
choose six to are above 80% four are
below 50% you have to get funded you
have to sell the stuff what do you think
you're going to show people
yes out-of-sample testing well this is
of course about data dredging using the
same data set until it gives you the
p-value that you want there there is
some scientific research now that says
that behavioral advertising suffers from
enormous P hacking it's like nothing but
P hacking because you want to sell stuff
right and of course there's always the
assumption that the model that you have
developed that the distribution of the
data that you have not used is the same
if you do not use that assumption it
worth nothing that assumption is
practical in some instances but not
necessarily this is something if you
take Tom Mitchell's handbook from the
first to the last page he's warning
against that the point is there are a
lot of trade-offs between speed and
accuracy between overfitting and over
generalization there are all kinds of
bugs that creep into the system
concerning the accuracy of the data
something you can have accuracy on the
data of 90% and it can be nonsense in
real life I can give you examples if you
want during pure native the example of
the eunomia research of rich quran of
microsoft research
of course the more data you put together
the bigger you aggregate the more
furious relationship get and it's not
necessarily the case that you can make
that distinction and if if you're in a
hurry if you're under trade-off
incentive structure is an economic one
then you might want to hide the fact
that you're talking about exploratory
research about generating hypotheses
instead of confirm them and then of
course we know that some of these
patterns are simply artifacts of
translations of real life so what is
agonistic machine learning mean bringing
domain experts and take the time to
comprehend on both sides of course the
domain experts also I have to make that
effort bringing the people who will
suffer the consequences of your
application and this will make the
output more robust and acceptable there
is extensive literature both in
political theory and in constructive
technology assessment it is very
important to get other voices in to make
your system robust we'll let Aaron say a
few words
yeah so thank you I was looking forward
to this because I just finished teaching
an undergraduate class on computability
we covered accountability I know quite a
bit about agnostic learning so I figured
talk for me what did you say agonal
agnostic learn it turns out to be a
technical term also Oh may I say
something oh well it mostly
is the opposite of agonistic typo so one
of the things that I learned during this
talk is that words can mean different
things and I think that was actually a
key point if I understood the one of the
concerns about differential privacy is
that although it has a very precise
mathematical definition of course in
English the word privacy is overloaded
and there's this risk that when you sort
of deploy it's and you tell people that
it is you know they don't know what the
word differential means and they know
what the word privacy means that it sort
of his math washing yeah it doesn't
cover what they mean by privacy but I
think that's actually a a feature and
not a bug in the sense that once you're
very precise about what you mean by
differential privacy some kind of
privacy it is quite easy to now look at
it and say ah that's not that's not what
I meant by privacy that's not
appropriate and in my situation and
that's good in the sense that the course
although you know differential privacy
is not aiming to cover everything meant
by privacy one of the things that it
does is it provides a language for us to
precisely differentiate two different
kinds of privacy different types of
privacy idiotic and so I think that the
solution is not to sort of stop using
the word privacy but to start to be more
precise about different kinds of privacy
we've formalized you know one very
specific kind of privacy called
differential privacy we should we should
identify these other kinds of privacy
desiderata and formalize them something
that Adam the point Adam made earlier in
this workshop is that once you start
embedding constraints into automated
decision making have to do if you want
to to still have automated
decision-making and have it sort of
respect various social norms like
privacy you are sort of unavoidably
formalizing mathematically what you
think those constraints should be and
it's episode of whether or not you view
it that way like code is math and that I
would posit that it is better to not do
so blindly that is you should realize
what you're doing and and think very
hard about when you say in a certain
context you want privacy like what that
means mathematically I know that there's
many people who have thought very hard
for a long time about what privacy means
but it you know when you're embedding it
into code you have to think about what
it means mathematically and and I would
say differential privacy is a like a an
example of a success story of doing that
in one sort of narrow case and I'd also
say that there are places where perhaps
the computational world view might lead
us astray and we want a sort of hume or
closely to sort of traditional legal
norms theoretical computer scientists
myself included I think sort of are
maybe similar to theoretical physicists
in a prior era we think of computation
not just as our you know vocation but as
a lens through which to view everything
in the whole world we view everything as
copy
and I think that's correct but that
doesn't mean that it's the most useful
lens through which to view everything so
in the same way that a physicist might
think of everything as ultimately
quantum physics that doesn't mean that
starting with a viewpoint of quantum
physics is the right way to view
psychology and so although for example
we know that in general these kinds of
inferential privacy harms you talked
about that I and the differential
privacy doesn't protect against that
that I can learn a fact about the world
and from that you know correlate the
observable attributes with of you with
something that I that you might not want
me to know we know that in general
that's like impossible to protect
against in the worst case unless we sort
of destroy all access to data but that
doesn't like it doesn't mean I guess
that we should give up on it because
it's not a sort of the kind of thing we
can achieve in the worst case it makes
sense to think about regulation and and
sort of legal remedies when people do
these things and so I would say that
like when it comes to code when it comes
to sort of embedding in algorithms
directly norms of privacy we have to you
know it we unavoidably have to think
mathematically and we you know
differential privacy it is the beyond a
differential privacy workshop we should
think of this as sort of the one
building block in what will eventually
be a larger sort of benefits a larger
categorization of different kinds of
privacy but four four four kinds of
privacy that are that are sort of not
possible to promise that a technical
level in the worst case of course
there's still a you know this is sort of
exactly to place where we're traditional
legal
remedies are useful question so I want
to say that in terms of content traders
I think because many of us if you wake
us up in the middle tonight we say the
privacy turning all of those don't ever
take a definition and so all these just
simple way and a well and also I think
first talking this workshop talked about
exactly some of the end of the worries
that you are already I think what some
different is that we feel that abuse and
there's a lot of a success in modeling
part of problem even the tip to do
humans making progress on them and this
progress is T meaningful and partial and
our view is that is not for differential
privacy it's not that personalization of
targeting wouldn't happen it just that
it would happen and also the other
hounds would happen as well and finally
I think that the difference with the two
issues we talked about and protecting
the data people in the dataset and the
targeting the difference is much more in
the world of incentives and in the world
of legal constraints then in the world
of process and in the world
or for my thought in the following sense
for some reason through this magic of
differential privacy we should be showed
that you can do what they want to do
anyway which is to learn models machine
learning models without sacrificing the
data of people within the data set on
the other hand if you want to target
individuals when you want to show them
ads or to do any of the other things we
want to do we can show that you cannot
do exactly what you want to do you have
to sacrifice something so the problem is
incentives and in telling them no you
cannot do everything you want to do
because now there is no CS magic or
mathematic that can help you do exactly
what you want to do and without
sacrificing later because what you want
to do is exactly to target them to
sacrifice and so it doesn't matter if a
computer or computer scientist will be
educated in in society and computation
and go to the world knowing all of that
and the fresher privacy will say again
and again and again but it doesn't do
the other things if we don't manage to
take in the incentives and the companies
have to reduce the data nothing would
help but I don't have to agree that it
doesn't matter it matters enormously
that computer scientists realize what
can be done with what they have worked
out and I think this shows that you
cannot solve these problems by means of
formalization because you have to agree
on a task and that makes all the
difference and this is and that task has
to be there translated into a machine
readable stuff so there you get the
formalization but the an engineer or
computer scientist that says oh but
that's not that that's just the economic
influence ain't obstructed you shouldn't
do that because your knowledge is so
important
this process question is who's doing
this what's the incentives offseason
that's what agonistic machine learning
is about right so we totally agree
actually
right I think there's much more
agreement than the disagreement is
deception degrees of disagreement that's
what we're saying all the time why are
you telling us it will not I think there
are some disagreements maybe not with
everybody
that's my when I give this sort of talks
to audiences then the doctors in the
audience or even the lawyers or the
whatever they they begin to look in
increasingly angry at me because you can
see the thing you're taking our toy away
you just discovered this the data
scientists in the audience they look at
me like and and this is the same upset
worried we're on the same side right so
can it just one one sale of this I think
we are on the same side and we share a
lot of I mean we are here because we
share one of a common goals what
triggered me
maybe a little too strongly was the
worry that the presentation assigning
many Falls to a specific technology that
I think it's on your side really I think
it's exactly doing what you wanted not
everything you want but were it applies
it exactly doing what you want I think
this is this is primarily because for
audiences that don't understand the
tension
see this looks like a very good way to
justify why we are ignoring or we want
to kill this I think the opposition
unfortunately I understand you think the
opposite but the way it was presented
went through this way I did for many
audiences it will go this way there are
a lot of criticism of differential
privacy which is not the right criticism
we have a lot of person which is the
righteous many of us are proving
impossibility resolves about the first
privacy we're doing that the spot you
have to face the criticism of people
outside your own interpretive community
that's if you don't do that people are
not to interpretation should at least be
correct and yeah all right I think it
state has been waiting yes I'm so sorry
I know it's like we have had this
amazing week together and I feel like
it's not just about this talk but it's
like kind of concluding something that's
going on because also alone II did talk
yesterday that was very much around this
and you know I we're both involved with
ACM fat and there's like a huge
compensation of you know what Aaron put
very nicely if we're using similar terms
and we're trying to differentiate them
and there's something going on there and
I like for me a you know coming from
privacy like we have the same problem
with anonymous communications if you if
you remember that discussion people
thought they're anonymous and they did
all sorts of things every day
it was like on the individual level
right like people in research started
using privacy as a term when they
actually meant security or secrecy or
confidentiality so that was a terrible
thing to do but they did that in many
papers then there were companies that
said we have privacy solutions and that
way got people's data and sold it so
like there's all these ways in which
these terms oh yeah and then it's really
important some of these technologies and
I think that's part of what MIT is
trying to say say we're enabling privacy
while enabling technologies that intrude
upon privacy right and that's where
things get really quickly and then
there's on top of that I think with
fairness we have people saying you know
what it means to be fair and reach
justice is something that communities
have been thinking about a lot and the a
historical approach is kind of breaking
them so there's even dos tensions so I
feel like we're in the midst of
something that is affecting all of our
communities very deeply and I want to
take this not as a kind of like you know
I understand that they've been working
on the special privacy and you can look
at this talk and many cryptographers in
our anonymous communications people feel
like that - oh you enable child porn
anything oh it's really important we
have this right like this thing is the
emotional part and they want to really
respect that is hard but I also think
that this divergence and vocabulary is
not just a vocabulary issue that's a
power issue and it's like an issue of
what we're doing and how it's affecting
the world right and I wonder how we can
systematize this conversation rather
than seeing it just as attention
[Applause]
[ __ ]